Welcome, everybody to an oom call, we'll answer your questions that you submitted. Remember to check the member site.
We have a number of announcements in there.
We've lowered the follow-up phone visit fee and we have a self-scheduling option now. You certainly can call the clinic.
Oh, we have a little bit more constricted hours in the winter time. So it's pretty easy to self-scheduling. We also have that available on the member site and on the web site as well.
So also a bunch of new videos in the lab section. Ever I promised I was going to get videos out to help you better understand your labs.
So I've been creating those. Those are in the lab section. They're also on the courses. I think I'm putting them on mainly the one on the view course. Also making blog posts regarding them too.
So I don't know if anything else is new in there is what the schedule looks like.
So go ahead and click on that. You can click on the follow-up info form. That's the form that you have to fill out so I know what we're going to be talking about at the call and you can pay for the schedule right there at the bottom two.
So the whole page of the member site and a couple of other places different pages on the member site. And again, it's on the website. So and it allows you to choose a zoom call. So and I would prefer that you choose the zoom call option if we're going to go over labs.
It just makes it easy because I can share my screen with you have the lab up but I can circle things and it just I think it's better educational experience to go over this. Also remember all the courses are available for you.
And we've got well over 1100 blog posts now so that adding all my videos to the blog post too.
First question. Let's get going on this as cancer cells die off. How does our body get rid of them? How are they expelled?
So cancer when cancer cells die they die through a process of apoptosis. So apoptosis is normal program cell death.
I have several blog posts about this. I think I call them apoptosis one of an apoptosis two or one with some videos about it.
So cancer cells can also die through abnormal ways pathological cell that typically that's how cancer cells die when you are exposed to chemotherapy.
So chemotherapy is an oxidized agent it's a poison and any time a cell is poisoned it dies through a pathological death through a cell license. So the cell license needed breaks apart it bursts through an oxidative process that's the danger of oxidizing agents that you're exposed to chemicals.
And additives, color and flavor, all these chemicals that are diet they can they act as oxidizing agents they act as poisons and they cause cell license.
So if you drank a poison how does somebody die if they drink poison you've seen in spy movies they drink a poison and they kill over their dead.
Well if you drink a oxidizing agent that's a very very strong oxidizing agent he causes immediate cell death immediate cell license and you could you could die quite rapidly.
Well that's what chemotherapy does and causes cell license of course it's an immediate cell death it's going into the bloodstream and you're hoping that it's taken up by cells that are more metabolically active a cancer cells and it is it is taken up by cells that are more metabolically active.
That's how chemotherapy works unfortunately your hair follicles are more metabolically active and your immune system cells are more metabolically active.
So you will damage your immune system that's why they need to check it every time you go in for chemotherapy visit they need to do a CBC see what your white blood cell count is before they can administer the chemotherapy because if it's too low another dose of chemotherapy could kill the patient.
So I'm going to make sure that your immune system has recovered enough since the last infusion in order to give you another infusion of a poison so it makes it sound like it's a horrible thing which it is in a way but cancer cells will uptake that poison more readily that a healthy cell will.
Therefore it will kill cancer cells bigger than it will kill the healthy cells though but lingers of the body your will kill healthy cells as well it does cause apoptosis sometimes but more commonly it causes cell license within the pathological cell death it's a process of the cell and that's a breakeed a part of the cell.
So in the case of cell lysis the cell just explodes it breaks apart and all this cell exudate is all over the place so that is those are called endotoxins endo means within toxins not something from the side of the body it's toxins from inside of the body aka the cell components that have just exploded all over the extracellular space.
And now the immune system has to deal with it can fire in immune response which is going to be just an inflammatory type response be a histamine response other chemo kind responses which could actually cause more problems more inflammatory cytokines to the area not necessarily tea cells that are going to kill cancer cells but more inflammation and fluid that is going to actually hinder.
Tea cell response to be able to kill cancer cells it's a negative side of chemo therapy so then that has to be carried into the lymph system and then through the bloodstream and basically detoxified so that's about through detoxification pathways.
By the way a cell dies doing natural methods are using the right machine or using herbal therapies those are stimulated immune response to kill a cell through what's called a normal program cell that or apoptosis and apoptosis is not a shattering of the cell it's not a lysis of the cell it's a it's a recycling of the cell material goes through a whole process of what's called blebs.
It's basically enfolding upon itself it's basically the cell is enfolding it just kind of breaking into pieces and then your body recycles that and reuses that therefore when you do you know right therapy or natural type therapies that are not oxidative therapies now there are some natural therapies that are oxidative but if you do natural type therapies that are not oxidative they're immune stimulant type.
Therapies you don't get the work cyber type reactions.
Technically one of the ill feelings post chemotherapy is a work cyber reaction work cyber reaction is defined by what you have produced that excess amount of endotoxins that overwhelm your body and make you feel quite ill.
You can feel a lot of malaise a lot of the team you just feel ill you're overwhelming your liver detox pathways so you are becoming toxic so you know cable therapy makes you toxic because of the drug itself but it's making you toxic because of the endotoxins that it's producing through cell lysis.
This both cancer cells and healthy cells so how are cancer cells expelled it depends on how they do hope that explain that more details you can look up apoptosis on our blog right there search apoptosis and you'll see a few videos on it.
Is there a way to turn off the beeped noise emitted through the right machine or laptop.
So the beeped noise is not coming from the laptop but it is coming from the right machine and also from the bulb.
Is there a way to eliminate it no you can put the machine under the bed you could put something over it you just don't want to you want to make sure you're not overheating the machine that's you have to be careful.
So you can cover it we've had some patients put it in a drawer in the bed side stand in a lower drawer and it stops the sound you could put a small pillow over it as long as you have air circulating underneath it you don't want the machine to overheat as well so make sure you're checking that.
Now with with amplifier jackhammer amplifier you couldn't put the bulb under the bed.
So you're muffling the cell that's really all you can do the frequencies will make a noise just is a byproduct of it that you can't get away from is horrible replacement therapy.
BHRT so BHRT stands for bioidentical hormone replacement therapy is this bad if you've had breast cancer.
Well bioidentical hormone replacement therapy there is a non bioidentical hormone replacement therapy so if you just went to your medical doctor and asked for hormone replacement therapy.
There's a lot of medication market that are not bioidentical hormones and they can be extremely dangerous very much against it.
I don't even know there's that many doctors that prescribe that anymore it just increases the risk of cancers of hormone driven cancers immensely.
So I don't I personally I haven't heard anybody taking that for a while though I'm sure it's prescribed on a daily basis bioidentical hormone replacement therapy is kind of taking the place of that it's said to be more natural and it is there's it's a much healthier substitute for the medication hormone replacement therapy.
But the negative is is that you still have to really be careful if you have a horrible driven cancer even if you had breast cancer that was triple negative I still wouldn't be an advocate of using hormone replacement therapy bioidentical even it's not to be really careful.
The thing to do is to run a Dutch test and you have to keep an eye on that on a very regular basis if you're going to do that.
Now there's times where using bioidenticals can be beneficial using some progesterone or using some testosterone you'd have to be more careful with the esterones because of even even if you have triple negative breast cancer because it is the bad estrogen.
You're going to be if you're taking an estrogen the chance that it's going to occur you only one step away of it breaking down into four hydroxyestero which is the more dangerous estrogen.
You also want to look at your COMT genes as well because if you have defects on your COMT genes and about a fan of doing a bioidentical hormone replacement therapy and all because you do increase your risk for breast cancer even if you haven't had a diagnosis.
So it's something you want to be careful with but there's a lot of doctors especially out on the west coast that are really big in doing bioidentical hormones and it's very common to keep a person feeling younger in many ways and I'm not saying it doesn't have benefits but it also has risks.
Do oncologists really believe that their care has to start immediately?
Well that's kind of a loaded question. I think the truth is is that different oncologists believe different things and it's hard to make a gross and have a gross answer to that because everybody's different.
I do believe there's a lot of oncologists that really think that you need to start their care immediately in your chance of recovery and overcoming your illness increases the faster that you can the earlier that you can diagnose a cancer or the faster you can start care.
But I do believe that the reason why they believe that is because they've been brainwashed by the pharmaceutical industry.
There's not a lot of evidence that supports that.
Now I would agree with starting care earlier if you have certain types of cancer so if you have a cancer that's growing quite rapidly then starting at a more invasive care protocol.
If it is probably in that patient's best interest, if you're going to start chemotherapy if you've made the decision to do chemotherapy or radiation therapy or surgery and then you're just putting it off because of other reasons that might not be a good idea at all.
If you're going to go through it, you want to go through it in the healthiest state you possibly can. However, cancer has become a huge economic, you know, bust for for oncologists.
It's only oncologists that make money off their prescriptions. All doctors make money off vaccinations.
So if they prescribe chemotherapy, their income goes up. Also, the cancer industry is really a financial industry.
If I was an oncologist at the University of Minnesota, that I was telling people to do herbs and to hold off on their chemotherapy.
I would be fired and be written up in front of the board, probably see have my license suspended at the very least. So they are under a lot of pressure.
I've had doctors tell me that they're in the golden handcuffs. They can't get out of it.
They don't make their own decisions. They are controlled by the hospitals and the big oncology clinic. So if I worked for Minnesota oncology, guess what, it's run by
besters, educated hospital hospital,
PhDs and such that art medical doctors at all, they're just trained how to make the most money for their industry.
Interesting on this. No, I had a patient. This was about 10, 12 years ago. She had metastatic cancer. I can't remember where, what her original cancer was on the top of my head.
She had metastasis and she was in the hospital and she called me. I gave her my cell phone because she was, you know, going through a lot of struggles. She called me and said, I'm in the hospital right now and I am so bad. She was why she was the radiologist oncologist was just in here.
She said, if I don't start radiation immediately, I'll be dead in two weeks.
But I said, what? She was, it just makes me so bad. How can they say that? How can she say, how can they say that? Understand this woman was very much against doing any radiation.
She was so upset and I talked her through it and we just tried to reason together like I always do. It's like you know that you're under a lot of pressure, but it doesn't necessarily mean that their recommendation is bad.
Just because we maybe disagree with their bedside better. We disagree with their high pressure tactics. Doesn't necessarily mean that their recommendation is wrong.
But all came down to she was having difficulty walking. She had metastasis to the spine. She couldn't, you know, she was, she had pain that was so bad.
She finally agreed to the radiation. So she called the nurse and she said, okay, I want to talk to the radiation oncologist. He came in and again said, if we don't start the radiation immediately, you're going to be dead in two weeks.
So she said, okay, I talked to the other doctor. I agreed. I'm willing to start the radiation. He said, great, I'm going to have the nurse come in and get your schedule comes in and get your schedule.
The first opening they had was in three weeks. So they scheduled her in three weeks. She called me back. I have never heard somebody so absolutely livid on the phone and rightfully so I'm going to be dead in two weeks.
If I don't start radiation immediately, they said the oncologist. I finally agreed to it and their first opening is in three weeks and he's okay with that. That doesn't even make any sense.
Well, this is the nonsensical high pressure tactics that they used that effect when I was looking for some pictures for this post.
There's seminars out there for oncologists to learn how to get people to agree with their care.
I mean, I remember years ago, car practice were just lamb blasted for using high pressure techniques and it was just horrible on what they were doing.
They could even hold a kid to what oncologists do today, horrible high pressure techniques.
And maybe it's because they're pressured by the orders of the oncology clinics, the oncology centers, the hospitals. I don't know, but it's awful.
And my one of the main things that we have always said is you always have more time than they lead on always make sure that you take everything to prayer that you slow down.
There's always a benefit talking to multiple people and getting second opinions.
I can't tell you how many people when my own sister was told that if she didn't do chemotherapy, she was going to be dead.
In that many words by somebody at Minnesota oncology, she went down to Mayo for a second opinion and they said, well, we would even do chemotherapy in your case.
And they offered her immune therapy, which she did one session, she didn't do well enough, but I do think it really helped her.
She's still alive today doing natural methods. I just think that it's just sad. It's just, it's just downright sad.
So yes, I do think there's some oncologists that are brainwashed and thinking that they have, they don't start care immediately.
But I also think that they don't think any other care is viable. I think they think that they're maybe a little bit higher than God on the scale of knowledge and nobody else knows a thing.
That's what it is. So I think there's a list of the multitude of counselors. So nothing wrong with getting their opinion. There's nothing wrong with starting their care.
But don't do anything based upon pressure. It certainly don't make decisions based upon fear.
Please discuss how we women and men can receive a safe and proper biopsy that will not leave cancer cells in our bodies.
To later start seeding other tumors. That brings us to the question of do biopsies cause metastasis.
An autistic oncologist will say yes, they can. That in fact, I just pulled up this article right here.
It's that does state. This is from an August 2017 article in this journal that does state that core needle biopsies of breast cancer is associated with a higher rate of distance metastasis five to 15 years after diagnosis.
I think a biopsy, you know, you're going to go in with a core needle biopsy to a breast cancer. They have to go in with a needle and they're pulling that out.
And by when they pull it through the other tissue, some cells are being discharged.
So you do risk the increase chance of metastasis with a biopsy.
The problem is, is that that doesn't mean that you shouldn't get a biopsy.
So the truth is is that the closer that the tumor, if it's a breast tumor, the closer it is to the surface, you're your chance of causing a metastasis from the biopsy goes way down because you're actually pulling the needle through less tissue.
Deeper tumor, you know, your chance, you know, will go up because you're pulling the needle through more tissue and you'll be letting more cells go outside of the tissue.
But the truth is is that almost every cancer has given off circulating tumor cells long before the biopsy was even thought to be needed.
So I'm not against doing biopsies. It's the only way we can get the pathology of the cell type anyhow.
So you can't legally get a diagnosis of cancer without a biopsy.
So biopsies are a necessary evil if, especially if you are going to do any care through your oncologist.
They're a necessary evil to find out the exact pathology that we're dealing with also.
However, we've had patients, you know, come to us that say, I feel like I have, you know, you know, breast cancer.
My dog sister had breast cancer, my mom had breast cancer and this is growing.
They want to do a biopsy and I'm not going to do it. Could you just treat me as if I have that breast cancer? Well, yes we can because we don't treat the cancer anyhow.
But in order to get a proper diagnosis, you need to get a biopsy. That doesn't mean you need a proper diagnosis to treat it from a alternative perspective.
But if you're going to do anything in the medical field, you're going to go and, you know, consider any of their care, they're going to absolutely require, you know, a pathology report.
So you're going to have to go through that necessary evil. So yeah, there isn't a safe and proper biopsy.
Let's take that back. I think most biopsies are pretty safe.
You increase the risk of a test is this, but you increase the risk of a test just by having cancer. So it's, it's, it's pretty difficult to ascertain whether the metastasis was because of the biopsy or was it just because that you have circulated to ourselves.
So, yeah, I just, it's, it's, it's a tough call. There isn't any other way to truly diagnose cancer with those biopsy.
I have just been diagnosed with the great one, breast cancer can sugar in your body promote cancer or isn't just estrogen driven.
estrogen doesn't drive the cancer, even though I think I just used that terminology and another question.
Estrogen with estrogen receptor positive breast cancers or other cancers any estrogen receptor positive cancer.
Estrogen isn't driving the cancer, but that's 16 hydroxy esterone is attaching to the estrogen beta receptors.
And that is blocking apoptosis. That's what that means. So when you have a horrible positive cancer, that means a hormone is attaching to a receptor on the cell membrane of the cancer cell, which is an apoptotic receptor.
Back to what is apoptosis. It's the normal breakdown of a cell. You want a cancer cell to go through apoptosis.
But when it's being blocked, then it doesn't die and it continues to replicate. That's a bad thing.
So there's multiple pathways of apoptosis. There's an intrinsic pathway that's generated by the interior part of the cell.
And there's an extrinsic pathway of apoptosis that's generated by these receptors.
So when estrogen is blocking that receptor, that it's blocking the normal program death of that cell, and it keeps the cell alive.
And therefore the cell can continue to replicate and the cancer can continue to grow.
So it's not really driving the cancer, but it's blocking apoptosis. So in that sense, I guess it is driving the cancer.
But the cancer has to be fueled from something. So that's a totally different thing.
It's either being fueled by sugar glucose or it's being fueled by iron or it's being fueled by amino acids.
And once you cut off the fuel source, it will really help those cancer not to be able to continue to replicate.
But cancer smart. So cells are smart. They're just trying to stay alive and trying to replicate, though the DNA has damaged them and they're replicated way too quickly.
That's what cancer is. They were, look, they will look for a new fuel source. So that's why you might need to be tweaked and changing your diet throughout your care.
So yes, sugar in your body can promote cancer by you by it being a fuel source estrogen. Yes, can promote cancer by it blocking the receptors on the cell membranes of the cancer cells.
Therefore, blocking the extrinsic pathway of apoptosis.
I submitted a question last week regarding the metastatic prostate cancer with my PSA being 0.1 and indigent deprivation drugs being used.
I do still have my prostate and did check out your blog post on this. You already have me on TV. Go see TV. Go as a free T extract. That's a real clean tea free T extract.
What does that do? It helps decrease the intermoocant six levels, which is really important for everybody, but it's even more important if you're on loop run for prostate cancer.
Prostate clear for other things for the prostate clinic cancer mushrooms, corsets and turmeric, turmeric and corsets in both help that intermoocant six as well clear amino pack. What else do I need from that blog post you need.
Andrographis. So clear of this immuno mod a is a great source of andrographis four of these a day will give you 250 milligrams of andrographis and I highly suggest just like as many as much as you can do with your other supplements is to break it into doses.
So if you can break it into four, you don't take one in the morning, when you wake up one in a new time, what a four o'clock and one before you're going to bed there to even be the best.
So a lot of studies and andrographis with the prolonged the benefits of energy deprivation therapy highly recommend that this also has just some other anti inflammatory.
And it's a really good thing to come in inflammation.
And this is like a perfect supplement for anybody doing that.
All right, that was the questions we had come in.
Anybody else has any questions?
Wait a few minutes here.
The version of the right program is on the laptop you sent us.
You can see.
If you look up,
you're right program and go to look at about.
Oh, I think that what I just said you put six point. That's what I did.
So I did put six point. Oh, I didn't put six point for.
And let's just wait until 7.0 comes out for you because it was a, you know, it wasn't a real beefy computer.
So it was a refurbished one on a hand probably might work for two more years, but I just thought it'd be better if you just put six point.
Six point at six point four, don't function any different.
As far as an understand, there's no difference in power on your program for 6.06 point or 7.0 when it comes out there's no difference in power.
It's just there's some functional things with 6.4 that can be better.
A lot of people that have 6.4 don't like it because.
It's what extra couple extra steps to get to your program.
So I thought, we'll just keep it simple for you. Let's explain it all back.
Dr. Christie Bunk says to take soy because it goes in the receptor instead of the body generating estrogen.
I believe you're not in favor of soy. Please explain this.
So the, the soy that she's talking about is fermented so fermented so a does exactly what she just said.
So if you have fermented so it actually dislodges the bad estrogen.
It acts like like a crowbar and dislodges the bad estrogen out of that receptor.
So it can be extremely beneficial.
So it's a it's a great thing to use fermented soy as far as a product goes would be in the highland 951 that's fermented soy.
That's the only product on the market that has fermented soy.
You take fermented soy in like me so in food products.
You do have to develop a taste for it. It's in different Japanese cuisine, but it's.
You have to get true, you know, good fermented soy and then you'd want to make sure that it's not GMO.
Because that would be a problem too.
So product wise it's the highland 951 that's a fermented soy that dislodges the bad estrogens out of the estrogen receptors.
Any any other soy is it does it works exact opposite.
So any other soy if it's not fermented actually can can promote 16 hydroxy estero production which could cause problems.
I just received my new right what version is mine so it's really easy to know what version is yours if you just hit open home or open program on your on your laptop and it opens up and if you can see your name immediately then you're in version six.
If you have to go to documents and then open up true right frequencies in order to see your name then you're in version six point four.
It's also really easy to see.
If what version you're in let me just pull up my computer.
If you pull up your true right program.
The top bar you'll see help if you click on help it'll pull down and you'll see what's a little tab called about if you click on about it'll tell you what version you're running.
So that's how you know what version you're running.
All of you running six point oh when you open up your right and you open up the open home button or the open program button and you see a your name right on top you're running six point oh.
I see all the programs but I don't see my name and you have to go to documents and then true right frequencies in order to get to a your name then you're running six point four that's the hassle of six point four so.
Anybody that I've upgraded to six point four anybody that's received a brand new computer is running six point four so the person who just asked me I think you're running six point four Debbie you're running six point four.
You have a new computer so if you have a new true right computer you're running six point four.
If you have a older laptop HP laptop some of you have asked me to upgrade that to six point four which I did.
It's it does take more RAM to do that so I've hesitated to do that now and I just just make sure that their program their personal program is six point four ready.
Any idea why cryo oblation isn't recommended in standard of care instead of lumpectomy or especially mastectomy.
That's a really good question to be to be really honest and I don't need to be cynical it probably has to do with money you know most things are not going to be recommended that they can't make money.
So you know cryo oblation critics charge for why can't just the oncologist charge for it I don't know it's just most of the things the most decisions that are made from a medical perspective have to do with finances remember these hospitals are not run by doctors that are constantly reading journals.
They're run by you know Harvard graduated people that all they're into is making more money so it has nothing to do with patient care has everything to do with covering their behind from now practice insurance and pleasing the pharmaceutical industry who they're in bed with.
And I don't say that in a cynical way it's just the truth so it just is I have just begun taking 10,000 I use a vitamin D daily last I had a checked about two months ago my level was 55 I live in Iowa and I'm getting virtually no sunshine how often should I get my level checked.
Well if your vitamin D level is 55 that is certainly not high so on taking 10,000 a day is that dangerous.
None of your vitamin D level is 55 if your vitamin D level was a hundred and 55 and you're taking 10,000 a day I'd be the first to tell you to decrease your dosage.
There's nothing wrong with 155 vitamin D level still think there's any danger in that but you certainly don't need to be taking 10,000 so when should you get your vitamin D level check to get up two months ago it was 55 and you just started taking 10,000.
Well I would say a couple months however I would say you probably should be getting blood work more often than that so with they're going to do blood work to test CBC levels and complete that evolve panel why not ask for a vitamin D level I mean literally it's that's $3 and to that test so there every time you get blood work just ask for a vitamin D level.
And DIM be used instead of soy sure DIM can be used instead of soy it's go to the blog again and search aroma tastes inhibitors and you'll see different things that you can be used in place of soy.
I think what you're talking about is fermented soy so you would use soy again so you'd use fermented soy but fermented soy again doesn't act as an aroma tastes inhibitor it acts as a dislodger here would be the blog post that you look for just search aroma tastes of the blog.
It acts as a dislodger of bad estrogens so aroma taste inhibitors would be DIM and I3D I3C and I was slipping my mind right now but you can look up the different aroma taste inhibitors.
Tony wanted to know if radiation treatment can cause hard bumps on the skin like keyloids or something they haven't changed in color or size so the oncologist isn't worried but they aren't sure what they are.
Yes, it can so in the three carbonyl thank you.
Yes, it can so one of the dangers of radiation therapy is you could end up with skin cancer so I would use some essential oils on that make sure if it's a hot oil that you're adding a carrier oil to it.
I added some different creams to that most oncologists post radiation will recommend some post radiation cream that's anti-inflammatory many times steroid cream and things that's recommended but I would definitely use some essential oils and things on it.
I'm getting my implant surgery a January 8th, how long do I wait to send in a cheek swab? I would say right after your surgery I think I should check to see if the changes went over right away.
Yeah, just give a couple days after your surgery that would be perfect.
All right, I think we'll say goodbye we'll be back next Wednesday make sure you get your questions in and remember about the self-scheduling option if you have to want to talk to your mother anything personally just self-schedul and we'll talk to you guys next week.